one of my favorite songs he ever wrote
was the elderly woman
you know the one with a very uh oddly
long title
yeah um but that song is so beautiful
and you're writing it really from a
woman's point of view i think if i have
it right
yeah like like that guitar there i mean
would it be odd of me to ask you to
to to show me how you come up with that
well
it was really just i think it was more
of an exercise in the morning we were
recording we were all staying in this
one little
compound and called the site outside of
marin trying to make this
second record and i've set up this um
1960s
uh sure vocal master which was a pa like
the
beatles played through and uh they play
shea stadium you see
those little speaker columns slept
between the two
speakers and then that morning had a
thing that i was playing through the
speakers
and i think stone was sitting on the
porch
having coffee and asked
what was that thing that you were
playing and i said oh this little thing
what was that saying what was the thing
you were playing to recognize
your face
so it's just basic you know what are you
playing d
to c to g yeah
d c just one
finger
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and then by
not changing at all
small town predicts my faith
perhaps that's what no one wants
to
[Music]
my god it's been too long never
[Music]
thoughts
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah so she recognizes him but he don't
recognize her
she comes she's working in a department
store
yeah behind the counter more like a yeah
a little deli
small town yeah where the [ __ ] did that
come from who you i mean
where the [ __ ] does that come from it's
just a story in your head or is it based
on someone
yeah i don't know i i really i i think
you just sat on my shoulder for a second
you can you can dream songs and then
wake up and play them in the morning
i mean you don't really need to know how
to play anything you just need to kind
of find a shape
what do you mean show me what do you
mean find the shape right now
see so i don't know i don't know what
that is called but like
so you would go you know oh i like that
but then you'd
yeah and then
[Music]
you know that or like a shape song
large finger is pushing
pain
for your god and you got big
hands the colors blend
the challenges you
give me
see just another shape you know oh
beautiful
and then
sometimes i know sometimes i rise
sometimes i fall sometimes i don't
sometimes i cringe sometimes i live
sometimes i walk sometimes i knew
sometimes i speak of nothing
at all sometimes i'll speak to myself
hear god
you know yeah beautiful